اذا كان الهدف الاول للحرب في غزه هو
اطلاق سراح المحتجزين الاسرائيليين لدى
حماس فقد وضعت حماس شروطها لاتمام صفقه
التبادل اخبرنا بها نتنياهو الشروط هي وقف
الحرب الافراج عن جميع الاسرى لدى اسرائيل
عدم المساس بحماس نتنياهو اعتبر هذه
الشروط
بمثابه استسلاما لحماس واعلن رفضه القاطع
لها هذا ما
قاله ولكن لكي نكون واضحين انا ار ض بشكل
قاطع شروط الاستسلام التي يضعها وحوش حماس
هم يريدون مقابل اطلاق سراح رهائن انهاء
الحرب وانسحاب قواتنا من غزه واطلاق سراح
جميع القتله والمغتصبين من جماعه النخبه
وترك حماس سليمه اذا وافقنا على ذلك فقد
سقط محاربون سدن واذا وافقنا على ذلك فلن
نتمكن من ضمان امن
مواطنينا تصريحات نتنياهو جاءت قبيل
انعقاد مجلس وزراء الحرب والمقرر اليوم
لمنا قشه ملف تبادل الاسراء والمحتجزين
صحيفه يدعوت احرنوت قالت ان رئيس جهاز
الموساد سيقدم خلال الجزء حاطه بشان
التقدم الحاصل بشان بلوره صفقه للتبادل
جديده محتمله مع حماس لكن هل كل اعضاء
مجلس الحرب يتفقون مع نتنياهو بان استعاده
الرهائن ممكن من خلال الحرب عضو مجلس
الحرب الاسرائيلي غادي ازنكو له راي مختلف
[موسيقى]
انهم متفرقون للغايه تحت الارض حيث ان
احتمال اطلاق سراحهم منخفض للغايه مازال
الجيش يبذل جهودا كبيره ويبحث عن كل فرصه
ولكن الاحتمال لا يزال منخفضا وفكره انهم
سيحررون وهم حسب ما يبدو من المستحيل في
المستقبل القريب اعاده الرائ احياء دون
اتفاق لا اعرف ما اذا كان هناك ضوء في
نهايه النفق
لكنني اعلم اننا بحاجه الى اظهار القياده
في قدرتنا على قول الحقيقه
للناس زعيم المعارضه الاسرائيليه ايضا يا
ايرلا بيد يقول اذا اردت القضاء على حماس
عليك ان تخرج الرهائن اولا وقد قلت في
الكنيست ولرئيس الوزراء شخصيا ان هناك
دعما كاملا لاي اتفاق مهما كان مؤلما واذا
كان الثمن وقف القتال فليكن لكن لات
الاسرى في غزه تقول ان نتنياهو ابلغها
بانه ليست هناك صفقه مناسبه وذات صله
لاعاده المخطوفين كيف علقتم انتم على شروط
حماس والمفاوضات الحاليه ولف يقول كل
الدلائل بتقول انه نهايه الحرب باتت قريبه
ولولا عناد نتنياهو المبالغ فيه لكانت
الحرب انتهت مؤخرا لكن عناده وغطرسته
ورفضه اعلان هزيمه اسرائيل وفشل في تحقيق
اي هدف عسكري من اهداف الحرب اجل وقف
اطلاق النار ابو ايم من قال الايام بين
نتنياهو بينفذ شروط حماس مهما طالت الحرب
قاضي يقول اولا نتنياهو يريد اطاله الحرب
لانه مطلوب للتحقيق والمحاكمه الشهر
المقبل بتهمه الرشوه والاحتيال ثانيا
نتنياهو لا يهمه استعاده الاسرال الى
ذويهم احياء لان استمرار الحرب يعني
احتمال كبير جدا انهم سيقتلون بسبب القصف
ابو شهاب قال لك ابو شهاب اين هم الاسرى
الاسرائيليون الذين استطاع الجيش
الاسرائيلي الافراج عنهم في المعارك لم
يستطيعوا الافراج عن اي اسير بل قتلتهم
الاسرى كانوا عند حماس اليوم اقتحم بعض
افراد عائلات الاسرائيليين المحتجزين في
غزه لجنه الماليه في الكنيست الاسرائيلي
رفعوا لافتات تحمل اسماء اقربائهم
المحتجزين وتطالب بالافراج الفوري عنهم
واخرى تحمل الحكومه والائتلاف الحاكم
عن سلامتهم ردد شعارات تطالب بتحريرهم
فورا والتوجه نحو ابرام صفقه تبادل تضمن
عودتهم
سالمين